jour 10 de cette campagne électorale
déjà dix jours je dis bien campagne
électorale et non pas campagne
référendaire parce que depuis quelques
jours vous le savez il ya un match de
boxe entre le chef libéral la chef
péquiste sur cette question là mes
invités vous les connaissez je voulais
présente michel david
chantal ibm chelsea où j'ai bonsoir
messieurs dames bonjour j'ai envie de
commencer par la fin d'une certaine
façon est de vous faire écouter
aujourd'hui une intervention d'alain
marois de monsieur couillard réponse de
madame marois
je pense avoir ça a donné le ton et ça
donne le ton sur la semaine qu'on vient
de vivre
on écoute il va falloir dès le début
comme on le fait avec le plan tarp
les investisseurs internationaux à
établir les plans rétablir les alliances
canadienne alors dans les premiers jours
de notre gouvernement on va parcourir le
pays
rencontrer toutes les provinces et
territoires canadiens contre le
gouvernement fédéral
d'abord et avant tout pour parler
d'économie d'emploi d'abord et avant
tout parler d'économie d'emploi et en
indiquant chaque fois notre espoir et
notre désir que la question de la du
caractère spécifique du québec soit un
jour reconnu pleinement par la concision
canadien
alors je suis absolument estomaqué de
voir monsieur oui couillard vouloir se
lancer
est ce que c'est le cas dans une
nouvelle ronde constitutionnelle est ce
qu'il est en train de vouloir devenir le
monsieur le capitaine canada s qui a
déjà parlé à monsieur harper de cette
volonté qu'ils avaient de réouvrir les
discussions qu'est ce qu'il a vraiment à
proposer ce qui va consulter sur tous
les québécois c'est le décide d'aller
dans cette direction c'est un peu
difficile à suivre une carpe un souci
qui est aussi facile à suivre que ça
c'est presque surréaliste on n'est pas
assez de plusieurs jours sur la
souveraineté référendum et là
aujourd'hui on a basculé dans le
renouvellement du fédéralisme
discussions constitutionnelles peut-être
tournée canadienne ue
michel david premières impressions web à
partir du moment où monsieur couillard
accuse continuellement que madame marois
d'avoir un agenda caché un moment donné
il faut qu'ils présentent le site
maintenant la façon dont ces parties là
moi je me souviens que le dernier chef
libéral qui a commencé à ouvrir la porte
et est suggéré que peut-être on
reconnaisse la société distingue c'était
jean charest en 98 il s'est fait fermer
la porte sur les doigts par jean
chrétien
il y avait exactement qui lui avait dit
la constitution n'est pas un magasin
général où on peut prendre ce qu'on veut
à lorsque monsieur couillard doit
espérer là c'est que personne fait ferme
la porte avant la fin de la campagne le
8 avril ce sera toujours un moindre mal
y a personne qui va fermer la porte
si le 8 avril pour la bonne et simple
monsieur harper a pas d'intention de
s'embarquer dans ce genre de
conversation nommé aussi parce que
le chef de l'opposition officielle à
ottawa temps mais ce mannequin et aussi
de cette école il va chanter ce refrain
l'homme et attendez vous parce que tout
à coup les premiers ministres sortent de
leur bureau poté oui/non ans arrivera
pour michel sûr sur cette journée là
parce que je répète il ya un côté
surréaliste ça va très très vite et on
ne pensait pas aller si lourd en aussi
peu de temps donc c'est vrai sauf que
dont on est encore dans une journée où
on parle de constitution de référendum
de la classe du québec de l'avenir du
québec au lieu de parler de garderie de
python et jeu phare des valeurs
alors ça c'est une journée de perdue ou
madame marois quand même même si elle
réussit qu'à peut-être ascari quelques
points contre monsieur couillard en
disant vous accusez vous allez faire à
nous faire un référendum sans
constitution
à la fin on est en train de parler
d'autre chose que du plan de match de
madame marois et ça et à chaque fois
qu'elle fait ça à réveil des
fédéralistes de notre côté donc on est
encore dans l'immense effet pkp de
dimanche dernier et madame marois a été
sa campagne a été dérouté beaucoup de
souveraineté sont contents de ça est ce
que elle est profondément sûrement pas
écouter monsieur péladeau je suis
convaincu que son plein match de potes
de faire dérailler la campagne du parti
québécois
c'était je pense de convaincre et les
souverainistes son ardeur souverainisme
pour faire oublier son passé de méchant
capitalisme et y en a tellement mis que
il a effectivement fait déraper la
campagne et madame marois de cristal est
sur la défensive et continuellement mais
j'ai écouté elle est en train de parler
de frontières de des citoyennetés
données radar c'est proprement
hallucinant et elle-même d'autres
s'entendre à doit pas croire ce que
c'est ce qu'elle était attendue
parce que pour chantal pour toute une
frange au québec elle est des vieux
nationale et des souverainistes la
première heure
pour eux c'est celle là c'est le réveil
c'est la troisième chance possible loin
puis enlevée
la rapidité avec laquelle aux jeux du
cirque jacques parizeau ou 19 lapointe
et compagnies se sont entendues clos
monter aux barricades pour défendre
pierre karl péladeau je pense que si on
avait dit agir duceppe ya trois ou
quatre ans dans un rêve qui allait se
lever pour défendre pierre karl péladeau
un grand homme il m'a dit qu'il y en a
un qui n'arriveraient jamais assez bons
pour faire ça mais le problème c'est que
tout ça ça envoie le même message à des
lecteurs
on est dans une campagne référendaire la
question dans l'urne c'est plus voulez
vous qui voyez vous comme gouvernement
c'est vous avez vous un référendum dans
le prochain mandat
oui ou non et il le vote kaki ce qu'on
se déchire
il est construit aussi de fédérer les
sushis bien sûr aimeront post qui n'aime
en passant est actuellement c'est très
clair on l'a vu dans le sondage par
exemple été publiés sur la région de
québec le vote caquistes s'effrite mais
il s'est fait d'abord et avant tout pour
le parti libéral ne s'effrite pas pour
le pq ya encore du nacionalista la caq
sans doute mais il ya plus de
fédéralisme qui a nationalisé en a
toujours eu d'ailleurs plus que deux
nationalistes alors un moment donné
s'ils si la polarisation dure depuis
lundi jusqu'au 7 avril
mais si le parti libéral qui va gagner
des votes symboliquement dernier
l'élection mais qui va gagner des votes
d'un os et des lecteurs c'est ça qui est
incroyable c'est que monsieur péladeau
sa job dans cette campagne si c'était
pas d'effrayer les cas qui j'ai bâti et
là c'est exactement l'inversé qui se
produit donc polarisation sur à peu près
toutes les questions qui sont
référendaire sur intervient seule sur la
charte aussi la question qu'on se pose
qui est la suivante c'est monsieur
legault peut-il se at il encore de
l'oxygène de l'air je sais c'est surtout
at il encore de la visibilité parce que
quand on tombe dans ces débats là il n'y
a pas beaucoup de place pour un parti
comme la coalition a mené avec la
lumière n'était mieux servi par le bon
gouvernement l'économie et cetera et là
on s'en va pas l'heure mais même si on y
retourner ce que moi je trouve plutôt
improbable qu'un franchement monsieur
péladeau serait dans son chemin aussi
parce que les électeurs de la caq si on
tombait la dent dure et - mais regardez
ceci presque un gage de ce que ce
gouvernement ne vaut faire un virage à
droite la modernisation sur la charte
des valeurs lui avait fait très mal
imaginez une polarisation sur la
question de faire un verre ça fait
encore bien plus mal à la caq à un parti
qui veut dire
ce débat là je veux pas qu'ils aient
lieu ça c'était pouvoir pour lui donc
sortir une ligne à la fin de cette
semaine
est-ce qu honnête vous dites que toute
cette semaine tout débat référendaire
tout être polarisation nuit et madame
marois va perdre des intentions de vote
et oui je pense que ça nuit au parti
québécois et surtout ça aide
les libéraux qui font ils font une
remontée entre sur le terrain je pense
que ce couillard a gagné là et il est
trois premiers jours de la semaine
dernière et cette semaine six au total
c'est pas une campagne qui est bien
parti pour le pq chez vous êtes d'accord
je suis très d'accord c'est pas tant de
problèmes du pays qu tu perds des vols
spatiaux travers beaucoup
ce qui est clair par exemple ce que les
libéraux sont entrés d'arganier au sort
au profit de la carte mais aussi
peut-être des quelques libéraux qui
étaient plutôt favorables à l'achat
tu penses à vos débuts et puis cette
année si on a rêvé lille l'ours
référendaire tous en charge
est ce qu'il ya des nous reste deux
minutes est-ce que des engagements des
promesses qui vous ont frappé parce que
je vais finir ma phrase je vais pas dire
ce que je chante à l'esprit des choses
nous avons entendu ce soit de la cac
pour les pme pour le décrochage sur les
libéraux pour l'économie d'un marois qui
vous ont surpris ou c'est ce qu'on
entend jusqu'ici c'est assez attendu
comme moi j'entends jusqu'ici c'est ce à
quoi je m'attendais sinon le vieillard
qui m'a semblé je veux pas de rien
antisyndicale mais je trouve pas un
meilleur mot de la coalition avenir
québec
et on en a mis on a joué très fort sur
ce tableau l'homme moi ça m'a semblé un
geste plus désespérés d'autres aux jeux
que vous l'apprécierez dérange convaincu
que c'était devenu un peu qu'airbus ça
c'est dit il ya peut-être des candidats
pour moi ça tombe mal pour monsieur
chercher ça c'est la dernière version de
la dq dans les dernières semaines avant
la fusion avec l'a4 il était parti dans
un délire anti-syndicats je me suis le
conseil général à trois rivières c'était
absolument sidérant maintenant moi ce
qui me frappe le plus c'est pas
tellement les promesses ou les
engagements qui ont été pris que ceux
qui ne l'ont pas été il ya une
aseptisation si je peux dire de la
plateforme du parti québécois qui est
assez frappante
évidemment on a laissé tomber la
question du référendum d'initiative
populaire
on parle même plus de gouvernance
ironise d'ailleurs je sais pas de la
campagne ça c'est paradoxal vu le tour
qu'elle a prises
la question des sujets la question des
modes la loi c'est oui étant de la loi
101 au cégep les antilles la loi disent
qu'avec demain avec l'arrivée de
monsieur péladeau ça ça a été retirée
voilà il ya il ya des mesures en général
progressistes ont été lacérées je vous
donne un exemple dont on ne parle de
plus dans la plateforme précédentes on
parlait de revoir le financement des
écoles privées pour leur imposer
d'accepter des études
vantis crif et d'apprentissage faute de
quoi ils perdraient du financement par
le but
alors c'était une plateforme finalement
qu'il était de nature à séduire les
khakis dernier mot dix secondes chacun
la pinière le parti québécois ne
présente pas de candidat contre monaco
de pépins ont dit vouloir l'entendre sur
la charte vous vous achetez ce jardin
oui et je pense qu'on s'en est servi
aussi pour essayer de changer la
conversation le ramener vers la charte
s'éloigner de programmes référendaire je
suis pas convaincu que ont fait des 9e
pour madame des pépins à ce point lors
d'un comité de stratégie péquiste
on essaye de robes de charger le post on
essaie de dire on revient que la charte
on revient avec la charte sauf que on
l'a pas fait faire par pauline marois on
le fait faire un vendredi après-midi ce
n'est pas exactement le meilleur
chapitre pas cher de sacrifier candidats
dans un contexte souvent comme est quand
même très bien messieurs dames toujours
plaisir à vendredi prochain l'emmène
débat parce que je le dis c'est le
premier débat voilà merci d'un film au
revoir